Earth is a Solar powerered
Planet at the bottom of the food chain
plants use photosynthesis to convert
sunlight into chemical energy food for
the rest of us I like eating both grass
essentially wheat and I also fancy the
odd hamburger from a cow that has eaten
that grass this whole ecosystem is
powered by Sunshine but recent Studies
have shed new light on how life
developed under our
sun specifically the role of ultraviolet
light UV radiation is useful for
breaking molecules up and triggering
reactions maybe that played a role in
the origin of life it breaks down simple
organic molecules and then they can
rebuild themselves into things that are
more complex if you do that over and
over again eventually you somehow get
life scientists think life on Earth
started around 4 billion years
ago a time when Earth's atmosphere gave
little
[Music]
protection UV radiation levels were 100
times
higher was UV essential for the
development of life's code
DNA we know that life on Earth stores
information in DNA
and then uses that information to build
proteins so we have the blueprints and
the bricks the blueprints are the DNA
and the bricks are the
proteins but we think that the first
life on Earth we used a chemical which
is much
simpler this simpler chemical was
RNA DNA's single stranded
forefather RNA is almost like a two for
one offer it does both of the
fundamental things you need for a cell
in the same
compound so it was simultaneously the
bricks and the
blueprint unlike other molecules RNA is
more resistant to the high UV
environment of early Earth allowing it
to
flourish RNA eventually evolved into
DNA and life started to have life on the
planet one important consideration is a
certain amount of light that's going to
be needed and a certain type of light
that's going to be
needed so if all stars emit some UV
radiation can life start around any
Star when we think about looking for
places that are conducive for life we
want to find a planet that might have
enough UV radiation so the star is is
you know bright enough or close enough
that it's providing enough energy to the
surface for life but we also don't want
to have too much UV
radiation it seems you need just the
right amount of
UV the most common stars in the galaxy
are red dwarf
stars if red dwarf stars can Harbor life
on planets around them there's an awful
lot of real estate like that
in our
galaxy red dwarf stars could be good for
life's chance of Conquering the universe
in a number of
ways one they represent over three qus
of all stars in the universe two they
live for over a thousand times longer
than sunlike stars and three they seem
to have rocky planets around them much
more often than sunlike stars do those
are the pros but red dwarf stars also
have cons for instance they might not be
bright enough for life to begin some of
the red dwarf stars that we know emit
less ultraviolet light than the sun they
don't give off much UV light at all
maybe on a planet around them there
isn't enough energy to get life
started red dwarf stars are also much
more temperamental they can go from
being gentle and quiet to having violent
outbursts Stellar
flares
these types of stars have incredibly
strong flares that means they're
shooting off a bunch of energetic
particles and radiation and light that's
baking the surface of those
planets if the star is just bombarding
the surface with UV then it will destroy
all of those those things necessary for
life it will actually destroy the life
itself these Stellar flares could strip
away a planet's atmosphere sterilizing
the
surface more research is needed but for
now the odds of Life thriving around
dwarf stars are a
tossup so far the only thing we know is
that there is one kind of star that's
definitely right for
life our son we know of life in one
place in the UN I and that's that's here
that's
Earth only 4% of stars in the universe
are like our
sun so if life can only get started
around these rare medium-sized Stars the
chances are not looking
good but life may have an ace up its
sleeve what if life can start on just
one planet and then spread
what if life travels across the cosmos
looking for
planets to
conquer Earth is our only example of
Life emerging anywhere in the
universe but what if life on Earth
didn't start on Earth at
all there's one idea that life on Earth
actually didn't get going here but was
delivered from space scientists call
this Theory
panspermia
the idea of pans spier essentially talks
about the transferral of Life throughout
the
cosmos we know asteroids and comets
carry organic
molecules but could they carry life
itself what if Life Starts on one planet
can it actually get itself to a nearby
planet is it possible that meteorites
could actually transport living
beings for life to travel around the
cosmos
first it needs to take
flight an asteroid is on a collision
course with an inhabited
planet so what happens if there's a huge
cataclysmic Collision on a planet
material is blasted off into
space the impact might kill life on the
surface of that planet but it's possible
some bacteria might
Escape hitching a ride on chunks of the
planet
surface a meteorite being ejected from a
planet after an asteroid impact I mean
that's not going to be an easy ride but
it turns out it's not as bad as you
think some bacteria are very very hard
to kill some we even don't know how to
kill even the impact that actually threw
that rock into space for bacteria no
problem if those chunks of rock expelled
during asteroid collisions could
actually hold on to viable organisms
that and it really could change the way
in which we think about life spreading
in the
universe if the microbes can survive
takeoff then they can start their
journey to a new home the odds of Life
Conquering the universe seem to be
getting better the important question
now is how long could that life th those
bacteria those microorganisms inside
that rock survive the space
environment exposure to UV radiation
could be fatal killing any life on the
surface of an
asteroid but experts think that
microbial passengers could still Survive
by hiding
underground it doesn't take much to
Shield a microorganism from UV just a
little bit of rock and you have enough
protection to just hold on throughout a
journey uh to the next body to your next
home